up next this is Juno the 13 year old
Sphinx cat oh well that thing looks like
Simon Rex nuts right this brother half
looks like my grandma's neck now Kat
what is this know where you guys are
okay what is it when you guys see this
sort of thing well they have a much
closer relationship with animals dude
than I do what do you mean by they
people different other types of people
from where it from San Jose
ciao very true very true it's fair
that's fair
you see I don't know where you're going
with this but that's well no I'm just
saying that cat comes from a more her
historical lineage is a lot more cat
friendly deeper than mine you know so
this could be in Egypt they have a cat
miss magic yes pink sky black magic it's
not black magic you don't [ __ ] drag
Derek into this I've gotta do it sorry
dear right I'm sorry
Brown magic welljust magic well no David
Copperfield's magic magic is white magic
right Derek Copperfield David
Copperfield is a closeted male that's
[ __ ] screwing people over out in Las
Vegas bro nice line I mean I mean taking
guys girls and make him disappear and it
was [ __ ] betcha
yeah that guy sounds like a me-too case
waiting to happen anyway I shouldn't
have asked you cab my bad I really
thought it was I
he has losses I do too melanoma having
too much honey dude
I'm out bro this thing looks like a
[ __ ] bowling ball where I'm from dude
nothing loses another eye bro that
thing's gonna be [ __ ] workin over at
Tiffany lanes bro that thing is gonna be
a damn bowling ball nothin lose another
is what nightmares are made of this
thing's scariest [ __ ] all
so the owner Persian what's up with the
but look at the background dude with the
[ __ ] the old statue the marble floor
viously person look at the [ __ ] cat
dude oh you guys do a thousand years old
it is lose and I its I one of his eyes
was hell out hey man yeah I'm out okay
dude this cat has problems they're
pretty nice though I bet it feels nice
to you know your ball sack feels nice
and soft that's what this cat feels like
this cat has the weight of the world in
his soul bro
this thing's been a lot for at least
2,200 years if you guys can not if
you're not if you're only listening to
this you have to see this cat look at
its one eye and say oh he was kind of
look at his ears huh
there's an eye hole oh that's an ear oh
dude I grill those [ __ ] ears up Boyd
oh so no we're trying it bro Jesus dude
could you imagine the pork rinds off a
cat dude I wouldn't mind lathering him
up with a little BB q sorry bro that's
what on the same bro look at that body
let's see that [ __ ] neck bone look at
the [ __ ] wrinkles a little wrinkles
here
Oh wrinkle in time baby set my alarm
clock yeah I damn he looks like my heel
my heels wrinkly like that I think
really that's the scene your heels bro
yeah bro I could see that you just wear
stockings row you look like a kind of
dude that wear those stockings bro to
make your legs still look kind of tanned
even though you about mine B can we zoom
in on his magical orb to the future
Derek that I yes
yeah the thing that looks like you can
see [ __ ] heaven from air dude look at
this Eve the one evil eye evil this is
where our stranger things broke his eye
looks like the opening and stranger
things the way does can I do
oh I bet if you jumped off a building
and landed right in that eye bro you go
directly to heaven dude you get a desk
job there or you go to 1960 dude don't
bring this thing around me I'd have to
kill it I don't I don't trust him oh I
don't trust him oh I would put this
thing on a very high plateau in my room
I would boil it at night I would make
sure it's covered in cotton and it
sleeps well I'd [ __ ]
dude I would make sure that it is I
wouldn't even walk and I would carry it
outside to urinate in the yard and bring
it back in are you gonna take care of
him like he's a like he's some sort of
special gem and I look at him bro you
could [ __ ] keep cigarettes in one of
his eye socket or you put your
cigarettes out on this eye socket if you
wouldn't know the difference
I would bro that thing remembers dude
what else we got
yes what's his name huh Jesus Christ
you